a 16-year-old Iranian girl who fell into
a coma after an incident on Tan's Metro
system has died CCTV from October the
1st shows armita gavand entering a train
then a few moments later her body is
pulled from the coach the teenager was
declared brain dead about a week ago
dorsa Jabari has more from
tan official news agencies in Iran have
announced that 16-year-old armit gavant
is officially dead the 16-year-old was
put on life support after going into a
coma on October 1st now uh she was last
seen making her way to school when she
entered a subway station uh here uh
Shada Metro station just east of eastern
part of the capital tan uh the footage
released by officials show her entering
a subway car and what happened in that
car is unknown according to the CCTV
footage because officials say that
particular train car did not have
security cameras officials have said
that uh she suffered from low blood
pressure and she passed out and hit her
head on something uh in that car and
then she's seen take being taken out and
then taken to hospital she was taken to
F hospital where she has been on life
support until uh Saturday now her family
have only given interviews to State tv
many Human Rights group both inside and
outside the country are questioning the
official account that has been put forth
by officials here and also accusing um
the establishment of putting pressure on
the family to uh basically confirm the
account that they've provided we have
had no access to her family either we
have not been allowed to question any
members of the medical staff that looked
after her to um verify the information
that's been put forth what is important
here is not only the death of a
16-year-old but also the fact that the
narrative and the story behind her death
is something many are questioning here
of course after the death of 22-year-old
Masa amini uh after being arrested by
morality police and then the protest
that erupted following her death there
is certainly a lot of grief in uh Iran
today as a result of her passing and
also a lot of question and a lot of
mistrust in the narrative that's been
provided by the
officials dors of aler ton